We have an idea that we'd like to talk to you about.
It's gonna be online any second.
This is gonna be new.
So, who should we send it to first?
Just a couple of people.
The question is, who are they gonna send it to?
The site got 2,200 hits within two hours?
1,000. 22,000.
They don't want you. They want your idea.
We don't know what it can be.
We don't know what it will be.
We know that it is cool.
Let's sue him in federal court.
If you guys were the inventors of Facebook,...
...you'd have invented Facebook.
Is there anything that you need to tell me?
One million dollars isn't cool.
You know what's cool?
One billion dollars.
I can't wait to stand over your shoulder and watch you write us a check.
Mark!
Your best friend is suing you for 600 million dollars.
Mr. Zuckerberg, do I have your full attention?
No.